[Music]
hi
i am zj i'm a data scientist based in
melbourne
i want to talk about this package called
disk frame have you ever encountered
this message cannot allocate vectors of
size
whatever so what is the issue here well
the issue is that r tries to load the
whole data
into ram so
it doesn't really fit sometimes if your
data is quite large how do you deal with
that
in this talk i'll talk about this frame
but apache spark
by for example sparkly r is also
possible
so how does disk frame work well disk
frame
is very simple it's just a folder with
many
fst files if you're not familiar with
fst files
see this website each file is called a
chunk
and basically if your data set is too
large
i don't have to load everything to
memory i just break that whole data set
into smaller chunks and load it chunk by
chunk
now once i can load the data chunk by
chunk i can do many things for example
i can operate on the chunks in parallel
so how do you make use of this frame
well the first thing you want to do is
load some data into the disk frame
format
so the disk frame package has this
convenience function called csv to disk
frame
you simply provide a path to the csv
file
and it will convert that to a disk frame
if you have multiple csvs you can just
pass it a
list of csvs or a vector of csv
paths well i'm going to show you a demo
using 1.8 billion rows so i've
downloaded the fannie mae data set so
the first thing you should do when you
started this frame is run this function
called setup disk frame
this will set up parallel processing for
you as i mentioned before i've created a
folder with many
fsd files in this directory so i can
show you the content of this directory
as you can see it's just a bunch of fst
files
so to make use of these fst files i just
call this function called disk frame
and i'm going to click the head and tail
just like a normal data frame i can see
things like the end row so you can see
this 1.8 billion rows in this data set
and the csv unzipped would be about 200
gig in size
so there's some more functions number of
columns and the names of the columns
so you can operate a disk frame almost
like as if you have a data frame one of
the key features of disk frame is that
i've implemented the deployer verbs
so we can make use of the player verbs
directly to manipulate the data
so i start with the disk screen i
created
i run this function called source keep
and this is very important this is
actually what makes this frame
fast so a source key basically tells
the program which columns to load into
memory
because there's 31 columns for this
particular analysis i only need
these four columns so i only need to
load these four columns into
ram so i just filter
like you would normally do with the
player to mutate
and then group by year which is created
here
and do a summarize and finally collect
so let's run that
that's running i will show you
what's happening is with the task
manager
most of the cpus are being utilized and
that's because it's processing all the
chunks in that data set in parallel well
as you can
see i've done a group by and created new
columns
in the meantime in about one minute this
was done on the fenime data set with 1.8
billion rows to learn more about this
frame
simply goes to this cream.com i like to
finish off by
pointing out a couple of things if you
do
have spark it's perfectly fine to use it
but not everyone's lucky enough to have
a spark cluster set up
so this frame you can use r functions
directly even those defined by the user
thank you